[Music]
well hello friends welcome to your
program 3ab and today Bible Q&A my name
is elalia deny and I'd like to say
welcome to class you know when I think
about Q Anda it takes me back to my
childhood you know the Traditions were
that when the teacher walked in we would
stand up and greet the teacher we would
not dare sit down until the teacher was
in class and responded and then we sat
down well right now we stand stand up
and we bow our heads before the King of
Kings because the holy spirit is present
here and we're asking you to Bow your
head too and pray so that today's class
would be a blessing to you as we answer
your questions my name is idalia deny
and I am so pleased to be with my
friends and family here at 3abn around
the table let me present them to you we
have Daniel pering with me welcome yes
it's good to be here and I notice as I
look we've all got our Bibles open and
that's the way it ought to be amen amen
and we have Jason Bradley director of
the dream it's great to be here and I'm
looking forward to diving into the word
of God and answering these questions
amen and we have Pastor Moroni with us
welcome Pastor thank you so much and
thank you those that sent in those
questions we're looking forward to
answering for you yes yes when I used to
teach I sometimes they didn't know the
answers and you know what the children
themselves as we discussed the the
topics we came up with the answers and
it was such a great blessing because the
understanding was clear so we are
praying that the Bible answers that you
will receive today to your Bible
questions will be clear because it is
God's word one thing I wanted to share
with you is Psalm 1211 and2 I will lift
up my eyes onto the hills from when
comes my help my help comes from the
Lord which made Heaven and Earth need
help today well the holy spirit will
help you understand the word so I'm
going to ask Jason Bradley if you don't
mind to pray for all of us here on the
set and of course the students at home
absolutely I'd be happy to let's pray
dear heavenly father we thank you so
much for the opportunity and privilege
that we have to study your word father
we thank you for our viewers and
listeners who have submitted their
questions they're hungry to know what is
is said in your word they want their
questions answered from your word not
our opinions or anything like that so I
ask for the presence of your holy spirit
to guide us and uh Lord prepare our
viewers and listeners to receive your
word today as we break bread together in
Jesus name we pray amen amen amen it
occurs to me that perhaps now that you
see the program has started you
remembered oh I had a question I needed
to send in and I forgot well I'd like to
invite you to send your comments and
your questions to our phone number you
can send a text to a number which is 618
3975 618 228
3975 for you instagrammers well we're
available through Instagram you can do
so at
3abn official at 3
abnor official and of course you can
send us an email if if you wish at um
Bible QA
3abn.org
and the question is is the concept of
religion biblical if so can you prove
that it's from from God and not man-made
she wants to know all right and this
question can be answered with one text
but I'm going to give you a few others
as well and that one text I'm going to
start with is James 1 verse 26 and 27
and it goes like this if anyone among
you thinks he is religious and does not
Bridle his tongue but deceives his own
heart this one's religion is useless
pure and undefiled religion before God
and the father is this to visit orphans
and widows in their trouble and to keep
oneself unspotted from the world in
other words you can think you're
religious you can have all the outward
forms and the the traditions and rituals
all the visible things and yet not have
True Religion so there is a kind of
religion that comes totally from man on
the other hand if there there is a pure
and undefiled religion that comes from
God and we have to recognize that we're
going to see both of those out in the
world uh listen to 2 Timothy 3: 2:5 and
I'll summarize a little bit here for men
will be lovers of themselves lovers of
money boasters proud and then Paul
continues on with a whole list of things
that we'll see among Christian people
religious people and he ends in verse
five having a form of godliness but
denying its power all right so they have
the the the ideas of religion but they
do not have that pure undefiled religion
and so much of the Bible is dedicated to
directing and instructing people how to
have pure religion Godly religion you
know we can go through the Old Testament
and we see Cain who had offerings he had
altars he gathered together but it was a
defiled worship Isaiah
29:13 Isaiah says these people draw near
to me with their mouths and honor me
with their lips but their hearts are far
from me we find Jesus saying the same
thing in Matthew 7:22 and 23 he says
people come to him and will say Lord
didn't we prophesy in your name and cast
out demons in your name and do
miraculous works in your name all
religious things outwardly things that
God wants us to do but Jesus will say
sadly I never knew you all right so so
much of what we see in the world with
the label of religion May truly be
defiled because it's not according to
God's Commandments or it does not come
from a heart devoted to love so let me
run you through some things here tithe
and offerings religious things
established by God Malachi 3 in The Book
of Leviticus gathering together for
sacred assemblies this was God's plan
see Leviticus 23 in Hebrews 10:25 Church
leadership and roles of leadership and
Authority structures within God's people
that all is established by God
organizing for evangelism Jesus sent out
missionaries God established Sacred
Music and musicians you'll find
references to that in the books of
Chronicles and of course in the Psalms
all these religious things established
by God for the good of his kingdom and
for his glory and yet we as humans can
take them and twist them and turn them
into something that is not God's
original plan amen wow wonderful thank
you teacher that's great now we're going
to move on to the next text that we
received and this one came from ghada
and we had Tony that sent in the
following question does anyone know
they're truly saved before Christ
returns
is it as long as you do not accept
Sunday worship how do you know Tony
wants to know Jason Bradley all right
well I'd be happy to answer that
question Tony thank you for submitting
that uh one thing I'd like to address
first is that we are not saved because
we keep the Sabbath uh or because we're
Sabbath Keepers we're saved by grace
through faith in Christ alone now don't
mistake it it's very important that we
keep the Sabbath it's actually the only
Commandment that begins with REM
remember but it's most often forgotten
um Ephesians 2: 8 and9 says for by Grace
you have been saved through faith and
that not of yourselves it is the gift of
God uh not of Works lest anyone should
boast so salvation is the gift of God
and we keep the Commandments of God
because we love him uh John chapter 14
verse1 15 says Jesus if you Jesus said
if you love me keep my
Commandments and so again we keep his
Commandments why because we love
him now I want to share some encouraging
passages with you to address the first
part of your your question does anyone
really know you're saved before God
comes John 10: 27- 29 says my sheep hear
my voice and I know them and they follow
me and I give them eternal life and they
shall never perish neither shall anyone
snatch them out of my hand my father who
has given them to me is greater than all
and no one is able to snatch them out of
my father's hand that's great news
Romans chapter 8 verse1 let's continue
There is therefore now no condemnation
to those who are in Christ Jesus now
notice it said to those who are in
Christ Jesus who do not walk according
to the
flesh but according to the spirit so are
you walking in the spirit or are you
walking in the flesh if you're walking
in the spirit you should have and you
can have Assurance of
Salvation Ephesians 1: 13 and 14 in him
you also trusted after you heard the
word of Truth The Gospel of your
salvation in whom also having believed
you were sealed with the Holy Spirit of
Promise who is the guarantee of our
inheritance until the Redemption of the
purchased possession to the praise of
his glory excellent news now Tony you
may be sitting there and you're saying
to yourself I'm not how I used to be and
praise God for that we can all hopefully
say that most of us can hopefully say
that you know we're not where we used to
be but at the same time we're not where
we ought to be
and so I want to share some some more
great news with you Philippians 1:6 says
being confident of this very thing that
he who has begun a good work in you Tony
will complete it until the day of Jesus
Christ Jesus finishes what he starts
Hallelujah God finishes what he starts
and I I praise him for that amen you
know he doesn't do things half-heartedly
he does them with his whole heart and he
ask that from us as well 1 John 5: 11-13
says and this is the testimony that God
has given us eternal life and this life
is in his son he who has the son has
life he who does not have the Son of God
does not have life these things I have
written to you who believe in the name
of the son of God that you may know that
you have eternal life and that you may
continue to believe in the name of the
son of God John 5: 24 says most
assuredly I say to you he who hears my
word and believes in him who sent me has
everlasting life and shall not come into
judgment but has passed from death into
life and so you can have assurance that
you have salvation now we do not believe
in the false doctrine of once saved
always saved so don't mistake the two
but you can have assurance that you have
salvation amen you're walking in the
spirit
and you believe in the Son of God amen
hallelujah amen amen praise the Lord oh
wonderful well Pastor Daniel moriconi
this one comes through an email it came
from New York so we want to thank Amina
From sending it in and it says should we
refer to ourselves as Sinners even
though Jesus's blood delivered us from
sin or should we refer to ourselves as
Saints although we all fall short of the
glory of God and none of us are perfect
what do you have to say to Amina thank
you Amina for sending that question in
it does sound like a dichotomy huh one
or the other well referring to ourselves
as Sinners to keep it helps keep us
recognizing our need of a
savior keeping us humble and depending
upon Jesus it's a positive thing for
that term you know in 1 Timothy 1 verse5
Paul says this is a faithful saying and
worthy of all acceptation or approval
that Christ Jesus came into the world to
save Sinners of whom I am chief that's
Paul talking he wrote most of the New
Testament so Paul refers to himself as a
sinner here in fact as chief of Sinners
he's recognizing his need of a
savior and then uh Luke and Paul refer
to the people of churches that they were
writing to as Saints like in Acts Romans
Ephesians Etc the Greek word translated
into the English word Saints actually
means morally blameless
physically pure ceremonially consecrated
holy also chased clean pure innocent
modest
perfect could it be that God inspired
these writers to refer to God's people
as Saints meaning morally blameless
physically pure Etc so that we would
think of ourselves in that
way 2 Corinthians chapter 3:18 says but
we all with open face beholding as in a
glass or a mirror the glory or the
character of the Lord are changed into
the same image from glory to glory even
as by the spirit of the Lord so if God's
looking at us as Saints we can think of
ourselves oh well if God's seeing us
that way we will become that way so when
we here refer to ourselves being refer
to as Saints by others possibly
subconsciously we want to live up to
this ideal maybe you've heard this
phrase uh you may not be what you think
you are but you are what you think
whatever you dwell on you're going to
move toward that uh dwells on it moves
toward there seems to be a bit of a
dichotomy but it seems to be that we
should look at ourselves as Sinners so
that we are always in need of Jesus our
savior and at the same time recognize
how God looks at us in Jesus Christ as
Saints thank you again for that question
thank you Pastor and um we're
moving on to the next question as time
does fly by we have a text from
California and Ruth says that a Muslim
friend asked who ruled the Earth when
Jesus was in Mary's SW Baron can you
answer that question well I'm I'm very
thankful for that question and I'm very
thankful that you have this opportunity
to have conversation with a Muslim
friend now in order to answer this
question we at least have to reference
the fact that uh this begins with a
proper biblical understanding of the
godhead there's one God father Son and
Holy spirit and there is evidence of
this even if you do a careful reading of
the Quran both would agree Mark 12:29
where Jesus answers quoting Deuteronomy
6 and he says here o Israel the Lord our
God is one Lord but the godhead is three
unique individual personalities within
one God you have this uh visible in
Matthew 28:19 where Jesus says go and
make disciples of all Nations baptizing
them in the name of the father and of
the son and of the holy spirit so who
was on the throne when Jesus was in the
womb or here on Earth and that question
is answered right here in Psalm
90:2 before the mountains were brought
forth orever you had formed the Earth or
the world even from Everlasting to
Everlasting you are God God is never
removed from the throne God was never
removed from the throne he is always the
rightful ruler Satan thought that he had
taken Authority and rulership away from
God when he said to Jesus when he
tempted him in the wilderness if you bow
down to worship me I will give you all
the kingdoms of this Earth but Satan had
only taken Adam's rulership which was
below the rulership of God I want to
direct you also to Revelation 4 and 5
starting in verse two of Revelation 4
immediately I John was in the spirit and
behold a throne set in heaven and one SA
on the throne who is that one Revelation
4:9 then whenever the living creatures
give glory and honor and thanks to him
who sits on the throne who lives forever
and ever there's someone on the throne
living forever and ever this is actually
the enthronement of Jesus after his
resurrection that we're about to see now
in Revelation CH 5 Revelation 5:13 says
every creature which is in heaven and on
Earth and under the Earth and such as
are in the sea and all that are in them
I heard them saying blessing and honor
and glory and power be to him who sits
on the throne and to the lamb forever
and ever and so Jesus now uh because of
his victory over sin through death and
Resurrection he's Seated on the throne
where God the Father already is seated
never was removed during the entire time
of Jesus ministry on Earth and then
Revelation 3: 21 Jesus says to him who
overcomes I will grant to sit with me on
my Throne as I also overcame and sat
down with my father on his throne God is
never not on the throne and that is a
blessing even while Jesus ministered
here on the earth he was fully Divine
fully God and Authority was still in the
hands of God and still amen amen glory
all right now we move on to a comment
that came in through Instagram so we
want to thank those instagrammers using
um that Medium to send in your questions
so from Ghana we received why was the
blood of a goat used on the day of
atonement when Christ is the Lamb of God
Jason Bradley would you please answer
absolutely thank you for that question
it makes me realize how much more I need
to study study this fundamental truth
let's look at the purpose of the day of
atonement you know the day of atonement
described in Leviticus chapter 16 was a
day of cleansing and atonement for the
sins of the people and the sanctuary it
involves specific rituals that symbolize
the removal of Sin from the community
the blood of the goat used on the day of
atonement symbolizes the final atonement
and cleansing from sin which is fully uh
realized in the ministry of Jesus Christ
while Christ is the Lamb of God as you
mentioned the different sacrificial
animals used in the sanctuary service
highlight various aspects of his
Redemptive work the rituals of the day
of atonement including the use of the
goat's blood point forward to Christ's
ultimate sacrifice and his role in The
Heavenly Sanctuary where he completes
the work of atonement for Humanity so
let's dive into the Bible Leviticus 16
verses
7-10 this is the day of atonement in the
Old Testament he shall take the two
goats and present them before the Lord
at the door of the Tabernacle of meeting
then Aaron shall cast lots for the Two
Goats one lot for the Lord and the other
lot for the scapegoat and Aaron shall
bring the goat on which the Lord's lot
fell and offer it as a sin offering but
the goat on which the lot
fell but the goat on which the lot fell
to be the scapegoat shall be presented
alive before the Lord to make atonement
upon it and to let it go as the
scapegoat in Into the Wilderness now in
Leviticus 16: 15-16 the word of God says
this then he shall kill the goat of the
sin offering which is for the people
bring its blood inside the veil do with
that blood as he did with the blood of
the bull and sprinkle it on the mercy
seat and before the mercy seat so he
shall make atonement for the holy place
because of the uncleanness of the
children of Israel and because of their
transgressions for all their sins and so
he shall do for the Tabernacle of
meeting which remains among them in the
midst of their
uncleanness Leviticus 16: 21 and 22 says
Aaron shall lay both his hands on the
head of the live goat confess over it
all the iniquities of the children of
Israel and all their transgressions
concerning all their sins putting them
on the head of the goat and shall send
it away Into the Wilderness by the hand
of a suitable man the goat shall bear on
itself all their iniquities to an un
inhabited land and he shall release the
goat Into the Wilderness now this is a
typology and F fulfillment in in Christ
what we're seeing in the Old Testament
and uh John 1: 29 of course says the
next day John saw Jesus coming toward
him and said Behold the Lamb of God who
takes away the sin of the world there's
so many more texts that I'd love to
share with you especially when Christ
fulfills this in the New Testament but I
am out of time so we'll have to do this
again sometime right all right thank you
so much all right well we continue uh
responding we received a text from
Arizona I don't know if it's Raymond or
Ramon but here we go Pastor moriconi you
ready yes ma'am all right this is what
it says how will a person know if they
are called to be a prophet wow thank you
Ramon or Raymond from Arizona that's a
good question well just let's look at
Samuel because that give us an idea
about being called for a prophet in 1st
Samuel chapter 3 and verse one it says
and the child Samuel ministered unto the
Lord before Eli and the word of the Lord
was precious or scarce in those days
there weren't any open Visions because
of the wickedness of Israel so recall
the story you know Samuel was taken to
the temple there as a little kid and he
grew up there in the temple and I guess
he was kind of the eyes because it says
that Eli was having a hard time with his
eyes so Samuel was in the temple
sleeping and then he hears
Samuel and then he runs to Eli and says
you know you called me and so for he
keeps Eli keeps telling him you know I
didn't call you and then by the third
time he realizes what must be God
calling Samuel so he tells him what to
do when the next time he hears it so
then and God does talk to Samuel there
at the first time that's the first time
he experienced that so the next morning
Samuel he's going about his normal
Temple Duty trying to avoid Eli because
of the heavy message that God had given
to Samuel to give to
Eli so Eli confronts him and he says you
better tell me what God told you
otherwise
whatever bad things is going to happen
to you so then go uh Samuel goes ahead
and tells Eli um that uh message that
God had given to him what's going to
happen to his household and that's in
verses uh 18 19 and 20 Samuel told him
every wit and hid nothing from him and
he Eli said it is the Lord let him do
what seeth good so he was convicted and
said well God's um going to punish me
for but he wasn't doing right so then it
says in verse 19 Samuel grew and the
Lord was with him and did let none of
his words fall to the ground and verse
20 and all Israel from Dan even to
beerseba knew that Samuel was
established to be a prophet of the Lord
so it wasn't that Samuel said hey man
guess look at me guys I'm a prophet but
the people recognize that this guy was
from the Lord and it was because he
every burden that God gave to him to
give to somebody else he passed it along
it didn't let it you know
stop and um so uh Ramone like if you're
just faithful to whatever God's laying
upon you as a a burden to share with
others or encourage others and so forth
then uh you can be faithful and people
around you might say wow Ramon's a God's
called him to be a prophet you know Paul
says in First Corinthians chap 14:1
follow after charity Your Love and
Desire spiritual gifts but rather that
you may prophesy then in verse three he
explains what he means what is prophecy
anyway but that he prophesieth unto
speaketh unto men to edification so if
you're prophesying you're edifying
someone that's building them up
encouraging them or exhortation is the
second word so that's imploring or
pleading it's a stronger word and then
comfort and then in the Book of
Revelation John sees people in the last
days prophesying God people will be
prophesying in the last days Revelation
12:17 says and the dragon or Satan he
was mad he says he was wroth with a
woman that's God's church or God's
people and he went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus so we see that these
last day people they going keeping God's
Commandments all 10 of them and they're
going to have the testimony of Jesus but
what's that you know John may have
wondered what's that but in Revelation
19:10 we see John so moved that he heard
the voice when he heard the voice of
Mighty angel that he fell down at his
feet to worship him and then this angel
said uh see thou do it not I am thy
fellow servant and of thy Brethren that
have the testimony of Jesus worship God
for the testimony of Jesus is the spirit
of Prophecy so and that's that Spirit
you know you're going to edify exhort
and comfort so God uh shows John these
people that are doing all of that
they're edifying exhorting and
comforting those about them so they're
prophesying in these last days so just
keep up that keep being faithful there
Ramon and maybe that'll happen to you
amen amen thank you very much we move on
to franois from vanatu uh the email was
received and um the question is going to
be answered by Daniel perin and it says
is hellfire simply the glory of God
Hebrew 12:29 and Isaiah 331
14-16 teach that only the righteous can
do dwell in the devouring fire meaning
that for the wicked God's glory would be
hell for them those are some excellent
texts to put together and let's take a
look at them thinking about Hellfire and
God's character Hebrews 1229 uh just a
few short words says for our God is a
consuming fire in other words that is
his character it's the nature of who he
is he consumes and what does he consume
Malachi 3: 2 and 3 say this but who can
endure the day of his coming and who can
stand when he appears for he is like a
Refiner's Fire and like launderer soap
he will sit as a refiner and a purifier
of silver he will purify the sons of
Levi and purge them as gold and silver
that they may offer to the Lord an
offering in
righteousness God is the fire and he
burns away every trace of sin because
there's no sin within him an Unholy
thing cannot clean another Unholy thing
this purging fire is God's character of
beauty Perfection Holiness righteousness
and we see that but we can also fall
into the Trap of thinking this is just
symbolic or just uh an idea but listen
to what is described by Jude chapter 1
the only chapter of Jude verse 7
describes Sodom and Gomorrah as an
example of the Eternal fire uh Genesis
19:24 thinking of Sodom and Gomorrah the
Lord reigned Brimstone and fire
literally on Sodom and Gomorrah from the
Lord out of the heavens this is a
physical fire that consumed Sodom and
Gomorrah as an example of the
Eternal cons consuming of sin and
wickedness not just an idea not just a
symbolism consuming until there is
nothing left in the next text in Malachi
3:4 says there will be nothing left
except for the ashes under the soles of
your feet ashes are a clean substance so
the physical Flames will not be
consuming forever they will consume
until there is nothing left to consume a
and then the physical Flames will no
longer be consuming we're not going to
be dwelling on the new Earth amidst a a
a burning furnace that's not a
physically burning furnace but let's
take that text in Isaiah chapter 33 and
just verse 14 the sinners in Zion are
afraid fearlessness has sorry
fearfulness has seized the Hypocrites
who among us shall dwell with the
devouring fire who among us shall dwell
with Everlasting burnings can we Sinners
dwell in the righteous holy presence of
God not without his righteousness
transforming us has anybody dwell in the
righteous presence of God Exodus 24:1 17
and 18 God's presence is as a consuming
fire on top of the mountain and Moses
then goes up to the mountain into the
the cloud into his presence you have the
three worthies uh haniah mishel and
Azariah they go into the fire but God is
with them and fire cannot consume and
burn fire and so they are protected in
God's presence and then here's a final
promise for you Isaiah 43:2 when you
walk through the fire you shall not be
burned nor shall the flame Scorch you
when we are covered transformed by the
righteousness of God no sin uh remaining
then there nothing left to consume and
the Flames will be burned out but God's
holiness continues amen amen glory
beautiful Al righty then we have another
question here this one is from Ben from
Marius and he sending the email and
we're going to have Jason Bradley answer
the following did God know that ham
would sin against Noah so why did God
ask Noah to bring him along to the ark H
well that's a good question you know I I
think that really we could turn that
question on us why did God create you
why did God create me he knew that I was
going to sin he knew you were going to
sin yet he still in his infinite Mercy
create he created us and he knows the
end from the beginning so he knew that
we were going to make a mistake yet he
still created us so let's look at that
um firstly God is merciful and extends
Grace to all even those he knows will
sin we've all sinned and fallen short of
the glory of God this
inclusivity demonstrates his desire for
everyone to have the opportunity for
salvation second Peter 3:9 says the Lord
is not slack concerning his promise as
some count slackness but is
longsuffering toward us not willing that
any should perish but that all should
come to
repentance God has given humans free
will to make their own choices even if
those choices lead to sin by allowing
Ham on the ark God respects this Free
Will giving him the chance to choose
righteousness you know our God is a
gentleman you know he doesn't force
himself on us Revelation 3 verse 20 says
behold I stand at the door and knock if
anyone hears my voice and open opens the
door I will come into him and dine with
him and he with me he didn't kick the
door down he said I stand at the door
and I'm
knocking and he gives us the choice
whether or not we answer the door and
allow him into our
hearts Deuteronomy 30: 19 says I call
Heaven and Earth as Witnesses today
against you that I have set before you
life and death blessing and cursing
therefore choose life that both you and
your descendants may
live Romans chap 2:4 says or do you
despise The Riches of his goodness
forbearance and longsuffering not
knowing that the goodness of God leads
you to repentance Ham's inclusion on the
ark provided him the chance to witness
God's power and mercy firsthand offering
and opportunity for repentance and
transformation so to sum it all up God's
um God's instruction to bring Ham on the
ark despite knowing his future sin
highlights his Mercy respect for human
Free Will opportunity for Redemption and
the unfolding of his Redemptive plan
this narrative demonstrates God's just
and loving character his desire
for all to choose him and the reality of
sin's
consequences thank you Jason Bradley
thank you well um we move on because
there is a quite an interesting well
they're all interesting questions but I
think this is this is a very common
question Pastor moriconi what do you do
when you can't genuinely repent from a
sin I know logically that it is a sin
but I keep going back to it because I
haven't truly repented I've been praying
for years now for a change of heart
every time I fall I go through the
emotions of kneeling praying and asking
for forgiveness without genuinely
repenting I want true repentance so that
I'm walking in God's ways what do I do
what do I do from unknown text wow yeah
you can hear the um desperation sincity
yeah and sincerity is a heartfelt
question yes and we already said that
logic doesn't work right logic doesn't
fix it just knowing it so it's only as
we see the sinfulness of the sin and the
pain that it causes Our Savior will we
turn from it in heart and have this true
repentance that you're talking about in
Romans 2 it tells us not to judge others
for we are doing the same things that we
are judging others then in verse 4 it
says or despises thou The Riches of his
goodness and forbearance and
longsuffering not knowing that the
goodness of God leadeth thee to
repentance I think that was just quoted
and then in Acts 5 verse 31 tells us
that repentance it's actually a gift
that comes from God through Jesus our
savior who can forgive us of our sins so
it's not something that you can muster
your own repentance it comes from God
and then in 2 Corinthians 7: 9 and 10 it
says now I Rejoice this is Paul he's
talking to the Corinthians this is the
second letter to them that we have
record of that you were made it says now
I Rejoice not that you were made sorry
but that ye sorrow to repentance for you
were made sorry after a Godly manner
that ye might receive damage by us and
nothing then in verse 10 he says for
Godly sorrow worketh repentance to
salvation to be repented of excuse me
not to be repented of so you're not
saying oh I didn't repent good enough
but the sorrow of the world worketh
death so that's what you're looking for
the um emailer person there so Paul he's
written previous letter that brought
conviction to the hearts causing them to
have remorse for what they were doing
against God they were God causing God
pain in what they were doing so we must
actually get to know God in order to
realize that we're hurting him you know
you don't hurt people that you don't
really know I mean you don't feel like
you do and James 4:7 says submit
yourselves therefore to God resist the
devil and he will flee from you so we
need to know God in order to willingly
submit to him and when we understand and
embrace the thought that he cares for
and he loves us even more than we than
we love ourselves amen then we want to
submit to him we know that he has our
best interest and he sees the big
picture yes then we can resist the devil
and he does flee from us so getting to
know God that's a key in true repentance
so we don't want to minimize that word
picture and then in Romans chapter 13
and verse 14 it says put ye on the Lord
Jesus Christ that get to know him really
intimately and make not provision for
the flesh to fulfill the lust thereof so
two things get to know Jesus and then
also don't make any vision for the flesh
whatever it is that's causing you to
stumble get rid of it bless all right
thank you Pastor moriconi all right um I
need to share the contact information
with you folks at home um just in case
you want to send a question or comment
please do so by texting to 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 you can also email us at Bible
QA
3abn V Bible QA
3abn TV and for you instagrammers of
course we're there as well at
3abn official at 3abn uncore official
now we continue with the questions in
taking advantage of time we go to perin
um does Satan have the power to
transform into an angel of Light or dead
people if so why can't he transform into
Jesus and other biblical figures like
Adam or Eve and famous prophets
everybody's eager to know what they look
like does Satan have his power all right
this is a really important question that
we we need to pay attention to what the
Bible says here now you're referring to
a text in 2 Corinthians chapter 11: 13
to 15 that I'll read for you right now
for such are false apostles dece F
workers transforming themselves into
Apostles of Christ and no wonder for
Satan himself transforms himself into an
angel of Light therefore it is no great
thing if his ministers also transform
themselves into Ministers of
righteousness whose end will be
according to their works and so we see
Satan pictured here as one who can
manifest himself in a way that appears
to us to be something other than what he
is in Genesis chter 3 Satan manif ested
himself as a serpent looked like a
serpent uh Satan or one of his fallen
angels manifested in 1st Samuel chapter
18 in the form of sa of of Samuel the
prophet now Samuel was dead at this
point and yet whoever this is Satan or
one of his demons appears in the form of
Samuel and this is why the Bible tells
us very very plainly not to be involved
in anything that communicates with the
dead I'll give you one text and then one
more Leviticus
19:31 give no regard to mediums or
familiar spirits do not seek after them
to be defiled by them I am the Lord your
God see also Isaiah 8 verse 19 and 20
write down that text go visit that one
again Isaiah 8:19 and 20 this is really
important because Satan is Preparing
People Christians to be deceived right
now people are watching movies listening
to songs reading books that are filled
with or inspired by or or connected with
those who are visited by Demons by
people from the dead Spirits claiming to
be from the dead and these are demons
that are opening up people's minds to be
able to accept deception so stop
watching those movies that have Spirits
from the dead repent of that stop
listening to those theme songs reviewing
those funny lines and scenes in your
head those memes those movie posters all
those things on your shelves throw them
out they have no place in our Christians
lives replace them in the words of
Ezekiel
33:1 turn from your evil ways for why
should you die oh House of Israel so let
me be specifically an abundantly clear
here if someone uh who has died anyone
doesn't matter who it is appears to you
or to someone you know it is not that
dead person it is a demon or it is Satan
himself and they might say things that
are
99.99% true after all they've watched
that person uh they've they've been
familiar with all their relationships
their whole life they know the intimate
detail of how they move their hair how
they smell how they communicated and
it's that. 1% lie that will kill you
listen to what Jesus says in Matthew 24:
23 to 26 if anyone says to you look
here's the Christ do not believe it for
false christs and false prophets will
arise and show great signs and wonders
to deceive if possible even the elect if
they're showing great signs and wonders
it comes from a supernatural force it
doesn't come from humanity and it's not
coming from God God does not work that
way he's told us to be aware Satan or a
demon can imitate Jesus or anyone from
the past they can use their words Satan
quoted the words of God to Jesus in the
wilderness when he tempted him all right
so Matthew 24 do not be deceived anybody
who comes back from the dead is not from
God study the word of God listen to his
words do not be deceived excellent thank
you very much all right we move on to
Glenda from Trinidad and Tobago it says
does Jesus Christ stay with the dying
until their last breath my concern stems
from worrying about loved ones who have
recently passed on can they accept Jesus
Christ as their savior and ask
forgiveness in their final moments Jason
Bradley take it away I understand your
concern about loved ones who have passed
on I've lost uh quite a few loved ones
myself and that's always been a concern
um but it's comforting to know that
Jesus Christ's love and presence are
with us until our last moments and I
want to share some uh verses with you
that will show you that Matthew 28: 20
we off often quote Matthew 28:
18-2 but that last portion of the verse
in Matthew 28: 20 says and lo I Am With
You Always even to the End of the Age
amen Hebrews chapter 13:5 says let your
conduct be without covetousness be
content with such things as you have for
he himself has said I will never leave
you nor forsake you God is always with
us um God's nearness to the
Brokenhearted let's look at that God is
close to those who are suffering and in
distress including those on their
deathbed Psalm
34:18 says the Lord is near to those who
have a broken heart and save such as
have a contrite
spirit and there's the opportunity for
repentance now we shouldn't wait until
we're on our deathbed because one we
don't know know when our day is coming
or how it's coming you know it could
just go like that and you may not have
that time but I want you to think about
the thief on the cross I remember I was
listening to this pastor preach a
message and it was so powerful he said
that as Jesus was there on the cross
Nails piercing through his body he's in
agony he's in pain and he's trying to
he's struggling to breathe yet he took
the time to have a conversation with the
thief on the cross in the last moments
his mentality is if I could just save
one more yes if I could save just one
more Soul powerful and as he was feeling
the separation from his father his Focus
was on saving one more Luke 23: 42-43
says then he said to Jesus Lord remember
me when you come into your kingdom and
Jesus said to him assuredly I say to you
today you will be with me in
Paradise God's desire is for all to be
saved amen second Peter
3:9 says the Lord is not slack
concerning his promise as some count
slackness but his longsuffering toward
us not willing that any should perish
but that all should come to repentance
and I leave you with this Romans 10:9
and 10 that if you conf confess with
your mouth the Lord Jesus and believe in
your heart that God has raised him from
the dead you will be saved for with the
heart One Believes unto righteousness
and with the mouth confession is made
unto salvation amen beautiful all right
now we move on to the next text from a
Known Unknown person sent the comment
please explain Dr Pastor moriconi please
explain the difference between
understanding that the spirit is given
to the repentant Soul who comes before
Christ seeking forgiveness in Luke 11
which says to ask for the spirit also
how can a person know that the spirit is
within them amen amen question or
questions let's attempt to answer that
in U Luke let's go to Luke chap 11 okay
and begin with verse 5 and uh this is
Jesus talking says and he said unto them
which of you shall have a friend and
shall go unto him at midnight and say
unto him friend lend me three loaves for
a friend of mine in his journey is come
to me and I have nothing to set before
him and he from within shall answer and
say trouble me not the door is now shut
and my children are with me in bed I
cannot rise and give Thee I say unto you
this is verse eight I say unto you
though he will not rise and give him
because he is his friend yet because of
his importunity he will rise and give
him as many as he
needeth and I say unto you ask and it
shall be given you seek and you shall
find knock and it shall be open unto you
for everyone that
askthe findeth and to him that knocketh
it shall be opened so in verse 11 it
says if a son shall ask bread of any of
you that is a father will he give him a
stone or if he ask a fish will he for a
fish give him a
serpent or if he ask an egg will he
offer him a scorpion if ye then being
evil know how to give good gifts unto
your children how much more shall your
heavenly father give the Holy Spirit to
them that ask him powerful so he's
correlating that and he's sharing the
best gift that God can give is his holy
spirit you know things that we ask for
which are more uh what would you say
appreciative possibly of receiving you
know if you get something without asking
for it you might neglect it or forget
about it you know the Holy Spirit
definitely was given to us to even come
to Christ in the first place or to even
desire his holy spirit the holy spirit's
moving upon us but I look at this that
we need to ask for the Holy Spirit
because that makes us more appreciative
of the Holy Spirit what we're asking
for um and then this last question that
you asked we know that we have the
spirit when we love God and our fellow
men in first John 4:16 it says and we
have known and believe the love that God
hath to us God is love and he that
dwelleth in
God and and excuse me and he that
dwelleth in love dwelleth in God and God
in him so we know by when we have that
love this unconditional or um Selfless
Love for others and for God then we
recognize that that's God because we are
selfish people ourselves so having that
in us we recognize that the holy
spirit's in US amen amen thank you
Pastor thank you family at home thank
you for your questions and your comments
we're going to take a pause right now
and we will be right back please pay
attention we're going to share this
information and you can share with your
friends as well it is a blessing to be
able to share this hour with you and and
when we come back we're going to have
some final statements from our panelists
so stand by don't go
away if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word
thank you um now we have some final
thoughts from our panelist we're going
to start with pen thank you very much
you know my first question dealt with
the biblical concept of a pure and
undefiled religion and I know there's
all sorts of people maybe you're one of
them who in your past has been kind of
hurt or or damaged by some false
pictures of religion I just want to
encourage you not to throw out all the
beauty that God has placed in the
religious experience there's all sorts
of things that are wonderful and
enriching and lifegiving from the
religious experience that God has
outlined us for uh for us in the Bible
and so spend some time studying that
coming close to Jesus and that's the
best part of religious life amen now
Jason Bradley what are your final
thought yes I I'd just like to encourage
you to read Hebrews chapter 9 and
Hebrews chapter 10 to finish off that
that question of about the goats in on
the day of atonement Hebrews 10: 11 and
12 I want to share this with you real
quick uh and every priest stands
ministering daily and offering
repeatedly the same sacrifices which can
never take away sins but this man after
he had offered one sacrifice for sins
forever sat down at the right hand of
God amen amen amen and finally Pastor M
Daniel Moroni you know that the one that
asked about repentance or true
repentance that's the key is that having
to have that Godly sorrow is to get to
know Jesus get to know him intimately
personally and uh just have that love of
his for you you recognize that Embrace
that and then you don't ever want to
hurt him that'll keep you from amen amen
well I want to thank you all for
preparing uh in studying and of course
we thank you at home for making the
program thank you for your questions and
your comments we see you in the next
edition of 3abn today Bible Q&A
[Music]